this is a deep team the key to beating the
golden knights you got to really manage that
puck because boy they've got so much talent on
all four of their lines if if you give them Rush
chances they're going to burn you and boy they
they do a really good job especially on the four
check in the offensive zone of winning those
battles keeping Zone time alive ducks with a
couple of early faceof wins and there's a long
wrist shot that gave Thompson a little bit of
trouble as he blocker it to the corner off the
Stick of Jackson lome silverberg battling in the
corner to keep the puck alive and W pulls it away
Nicholas W and ahead comes Howen into the Anaheim
Zone on left wing that's off of Gibson referees
for tonight's game are Graham Skiller and Jake
Frank the linesmen are Ben o Quinn and shandor
Alonso just over 3 minutes gone as the duck get
it through from the point Fen with a shot that
Thompson did not not see until the last minute
anah strikes first you know cred Max Jones
Max Jones Goes to the front of the net quick
little snapshot from Cam Fowler Leon just kind
of dumps it into the corner and then the Ducks
get the four check going good job by Fowler
for the shot and yeah I think Brett Leon gets
a touch on that puck we'll get a good look at it
here there it is he knocks it down and takes one
bounce and it's over the right leg pad of Logan
Thompson for Leon that's Leon has already set a
new career high in assists this season and that
establishes a new career high in points for him
and Stevenson took a pretty good hit along
the boards there from believe it was stro
and stro now Taps it back and here comes McTavish
finds an open dri stale score welcome back Jamie
dri
he can really skatee and keep an eye on the left
side of your screen and watch drives he'll get
on his force and he's just going to come in late
but man he is just wide open that's a real good
pass from Mason mavic who show great patience
and Jamie when you when you're skating as fast
as he does sometimes it can be really and now
labush can careful with it stro snaps it up the
left side cavish cuts to the middle gets it back
to stro is off Wing finds the man down the slot
kushin and getting a little piece of the Blocker
on that they get it back around and score Mavish
and Logan Thompson never got back in his cre
after the initial save onia lausin unbelievable
play to set up Frank vrono good play first of all
from Ryan strome but watch this little backhand
pass that is a thing of beauty gets it around
the Stick of hey who's trying to put pressure
on him and you know Frank's shooting that one
and that was behind Logan Thompson before he
knew what hit him Thompson got a little stuck
on the near he just plays it out of the Zone
Terry lead man on the forck as maro's pass
picked off by Zer he wants to move it ahead
and it's color across the line with Terry Terry
pulls it in St oh it was partially deflected by
Hy and he went right through the five hole on
Thompson that could be it for Logan Thompson
rolling great play by zus in the neutral zone
to turn that puck over he gets it to color and
R through the wickets of Logan Thompson and I'm
a little bit surprised Bruce Cassidy is leaving
them in that's four goals on nine shots for
so the golden Knight starting to answer with
some pressure Doria from below the goal line
right into the goal crease and knocked Away
by the paddle of Gibson stick so gets to
the rebound down in the corner and Carlson
angled off there by Fowler dropping down is
Leon but he's beaten to the puck by IA stone
with room walks right down Main Street makes
a pass and that shot blocked by La here's the
cross I pass and I'm not sure that he doesn't
fan on this yeah he just whips on it and then
John Gibson was down and Carlson just buried
it right into the legs of the Anaheim golender
it's a lot of nothing going on there between
Maro and lushin on games at T-Mobile Arena
Jones receives the outlet shovels it ahead and
Leon gets it in Max Jones Dives for it chops it
over right on goal Jones trying to get to
that loose Puck you saw him take a little
Peak got to it ahead of patango one hand on the
stick off the boards a little touch by Johnston
didn't quite connect with car niov with a
good read pokes it ahead here's silverberg
backhander kicked the side by Thon glove down
by Jamie Dale who gets the feet moving in his
backand pass through the logo off the Stick
of patrono cter Motors back in with it forced
wi got it in front and they score Alec Martinez
the defenseman coming right down Main Street by
the veteran Martinez here another backhand pass
that is intercepted and turned up ice and all
in one motion Martinez just whips a five hole on
John Gibson that was a strange one actually hits
the Stick of Gibson and then I think squeezes
between the arm and the body so a little bit
unlucky vgis and barbashev were tied up with
one another right in front of the Vegas bench
meantime play goes on dor FV tow drag and around
brings it into the crease gets it with a big
stop very talented Winger hasn't been in the
lineup on a nightly basis and it's maraso again
on the doorstep Gibson with two huge stops know
the golden Knight's going to be patient here
one timer rattles off the back of the net off the
boards from petrangelo and Now Lea without a stick
trying to just glove the puck away can't Dr right
to the slap they score that's a veteran team right
there Stone gets the goal right so you can't get
to the bench and you're trapped out there and and
now you try and create two on ones and there's the
two onone Mark Stone come into the middle of the
ice ham Fowler wasn't able to get to that stick
of stone and as a result it's a one timer and
gold the knights have got the momentum Mavish had
trouble with it off the boards and barbashev turns
back for the Knight speed through the middle of
the ice eel drops it off for stone back to barbish
right on goal he may have kick that on goal and
getson kept it out up and down we go here's Mason
McTavish with space long rot fat rebound Leon
scores second of the game for Brett Leon and boy
did the Ducks need that shot volume Mason Mavis
was at the end of a long shift I thought he was
going to go to the bench here but no he decides
to keep going what does he do he just throws it
at the net and that is a big fat rebound by Logan
Thompson and Brett Leon goes right down the middle
of the ice says Thank you very very much and just
rips it home it's another goal that goes as the
Ducks pursue on the four check vodan and pushes up
the left wall and it's kept in by McTavish Howen
finds it at the line hurries the other way kisar
in behind the defense Gibson made the stop penalty
against the Ducks Watch What Happens here Gibson
makes the save it pops out and then McTavish swaps
it up the wall Leon couldn't cut it off and
reek did kept at the line by Fowler nice play
by cam deaka n and that tipped on the way and
Logan Thompson kept it out had a little trouble
a mattio was all over him so he'll reverse it
around Ducks pop it to the middle White Cloud
with the keep intercepted color has zis behind the
defense he's in big save and then he kicked the
rebound just wide period the Ducks had a chance
to extend their lead but Logan Thompson keeps it
52 and a bouncing Puck that color will go off
the wall of a line Martinez keeps Stone trying
to bring it to the middle taken away and
fired off the goal post and one last shot
from lbushkin blocked to the boards cleared by
kisar and this one is over the Ducks defeat the
defending Stanley Cup champions for the second
time in a row 52 the final tonight at hon